We have,
I think we can all agree that political
corruption is a bad thing and you don't
get more black and white in this regard.
In the case of former Virginia Governor
Bob Mcdonnell,
former Republican governor of Virginia
bobbing,
Donald has an Alvin sentenced to two
years in prison,
24 months.
That is how long Bob Mcdonald will spend
in jail for corruption charges.
Last year at Mcdonald was convicted of
accepting gifts from a donor in exchange
for political favors.
This kind of personal corruption,
quid pro quo stuff is what we're used to
seeing on television and in film put
simply,
we don't want those in power.
Our elected leaders to take ethical
shortcuts and we shouldn't,
but our defenses are fragile.
If personal corruption is the only kind
we recognize and protect ourselves
against.
Unfortunately,
this is exactly the case in the United
States.
A little over five years ago,
the Supreme Court in the landmark
decision of citizens united versus fec
took up the argument against structural
corruption and what happens when the
political system itself is dependent on
money from private interests and found
it.
Last week,
the Supreme Court reversed a century of
law that I believe will open the
floodgates for special one.
The majority decided that political
donations from how ever large and entity
or protected as a form of free speech,
but does this misunderstand the way
politics actually works.
Though there is no explicit promise of
legislative favors for campaign donors,
politicians remain indebted to their
wealthiest benefactors and this that
weaves its way into policy decisions
that considered the needs of private
interests over those of the common.
Now,
the key argument against regulating this
kind of structural corruption is that
it's hard to determine where free speech
ends and political corruption begins and
that it may not be the court's placed to
draw that line.
The premise is freedom of speech,
the more speech the bed,
but my only recognizing something for
something personal corruption.
The courts actually do draw a line and
abdicate themselves from the complex
interplay of money and politics,
and I guess most people who accused
American politics of being corrupt,
do so because they see an essential
unfairness in the system reflected in
vast economic inequality.
That's getting worse,
not better.
As time goes on,
when the power of a political campaign
comes down to the size of its coffers,
it's easy to see how moneyed interests
retaining an improper advantage and when
that advantage serves to worsen existing
inequalities in the system,
such politics are,
at least in part structurally corrupt,
worst of all,
structural corruption more than personal
corruption perpetuates the idea that
individual people don't have a voice in
politics.
That putting the needs of the
Commonwealth first is impossible and so
it's pointless to try.
Ironically,
this kind of collective action
diminished by the free speech of wealthy
special interests is the only way to
protect democracy from the corrupting
influences at it.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching.
If you want to support the nerdwriter
and helped me keep making these videos,
you can go to Patrion.com/nerd
writer and pledges little as $1 anything
and everything helps.
Thank you so much for that.
If you have a patron reward,
do I'm gonna be sending those out
promptly,
so be on the lookout for that.
I'm not the first person to talk about
structural corruption,
but I wanted to do it my way.
I am passionate about the topic and I
want to know more about it in the
future.
I just find it really interesting and
really important and vital and uh,
yeah.
So follow me on Tumbler and twitter and
I will see you next time.